the days of small eu countries standing
up to the big powers could soon be over
germany's foreign minister wants to
silence dissenting voices
the likes of hungary by abolishing veto
powers
we cannot let vetoes be used to paralyze
european foreign policy and hold us
hostage
those who do that are playing with
europe's cohesion in the short and long
term
that's why we must say openly the veto
must go
even if that means that we ourselves can
be outvoted
while the german foreign minister height
or mass didn't mention any
eu member states by name when saying
that the veto was being misused and
should be banned
it's pretty clear who he was talking
about we can extrapolate as well from
statements we've heard from mr mas in
the past as well as
tweets made by senior figures within his
foreign ministry
that this is directed firmly towards
hungary
budapest and prime minister of hungary
viktor orban
the reason is they think victor orban's
being too overzealous when it comes to
the use of this veto
well hungary used their veto just last
week to stop a joint
eu statement on hong kong they've done
something similar back in april as well
and just recently budapest nixed another
statement from the european union
calling for a
a ceasefire in hostilities between
palestinians and the state
of israel we've also seen poland
and hungary team up to delay the
signing the uh ratification of the the
eu
budget just last year now what uh
the response to this from hungary has
been as well
victor orban the hungarian prime
minister is far from happy with german
foreign minister heiko maas
the european left led by the german left
is once again attacking hungary in an
outrageous tone this time on the basis
that our country wasn't willing to sign
a joint declaration on hong kong
that lacked any political weight and
seriousness whatsoever
we will exercise our rights guaranteed
by the european union's founding
treaties
when it comes to things like tax budgets
and foreign policy the european union
has to be marching
in lockstep meaning all 27 nations have
to agree to
any statements or any moves concerning
the big things
um what this move would do would be to
get rid of that and in the past what
we've seen
is these this veto being used as
leverage
basically you've seen one country go i'm
not signing that
until my issue that is most pressing to
me has been signed
what this would do that haiko mass is
talking about is almost certainly it
would speed up
eu decision-making processes but it
would get rid of perhaps some of the say
that smaller nations have in the
european union another thing
that's worth noting uh in order to get
what mr mass would like
it would require all 27 member states to
sign off on getting rid
of the veto and if you listen to what
victor orban in hungary has to say just
to
to what mr mass proposed we can't see
that happening anytime soon
political and communications consultant
damian wilson believes scrapping eu
veto powers can only be damaging for the
block's smaller states
i think it's a very useful device for
the smaller nations because without
it it's the the larger nations like
germany like france will just
bully the smaller nations into doing
whatever they want
every nation within that the 27 nations
the left
have their own history have their own
problems have their own
outlooks on on the wider world they
should be allowed to keep those without
being forced
into a corner or bribed and bullied by
by the large nations the problem with
the eu's is it really desperately wants
to be seen
as a one united voice that speaks on the
world stage
uh you see that they've been invited to
to the g7 meeting in the uk this week
but they're not one of the seven they're
they're a plus one
so they're really on the outside on the
fringes of it
and it annoys them that they can't get
that united voice
and uh and be given the presence and the
and the
the the limelight that they think they
deserve